in act 3 scene four of William
Shakespeare's o fell the jealous Moore
inflamed by the lies of the wicked Yago
confronts the slandered
Desdemona and the essence of that
classic situation loses little when
translated into contemporary
terms oh you
pretty Chitty Bang Bang Chitty Chitty
Bang
Bang we love you and our pretty Chitty
Chitty
Chitty Bang
Bang loves us
too hi low anywhere we go on chitty we
depend Bang Bang bang Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang our fine for Fender friend our fine
for fendered
friend look there isn't a dry eye in the
house well with lines like that how can
you make yes how can you exactly and now
to give these words a different
interpretation here is The Sensational
young dancer from sweet charity Paula
Kelly with the UCLA marching band to
dance the musical question Chitty Chitty
Bang
[Applause]
[Music]
Bang
l
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
EX